what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime opera and today i will be
breaking down a massive game-changing
moment in mha we now have confirmation
that new order the quirk used by the
strongest american hero stars and
stripes is likely the strongest quirk of
all time and what we just saw stars and
stripes do with that quirk was not even
human this is a godly power the likes of
which i never thought i'd see in this
series we are witnessing the most
overpowered showdown in the history of
mha so we have to talk about it if you
enjoyed the boku no hero videos here on
the channel you want to see more do me a
quick favor and leave a like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot with the youtube algorithm and if
you're new here or you just haven't
subscribed yet make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications before
we get into it this video is brought to
you by
manscaped.com the global brand for men's
grooming and hygiene products when you
hear about any grooming products it's
almost always targeted at women and here
on the channel like 80 of our audience's
men but being the chadley weebs that we
are we also care about grooming and
hygiene in other words we care about our
shenron and the dragon balls
manscape.com is committed to keeping
your treasure in one piece they just
launched their new lawnmower 4.0
waterproof electric trimmer and now you
can get the ultimate manscaped
experience when you purchase their new
performance package 4.0 bundle when
dealing with such a sensitive area you
have to be extremely careful no matter
what product you use and personally i
want to use a product that was
specifically made with that sensitive
area in mind the lawnmower 4.0 has
replaceable ceramic blades with skin
safe technology and a built-in led light
a cool new wireless charging system and
a new travel lock feature the package
also comes with a crop preserver
deodorant and a crop reviver toner spray
to keep your dragon balls fresh
throughout the day and manscaped is not
just about taking care of your tailed
beast the new performance package 4.0
bundle includes their new weed whacker
nose and ear hair trimmer for the
complete manly grooming experience try
it out for yourself just click the link
in the description to get 20 off plus
free shipping plus two free gifts just
use the promo code anime uproar at
manscaped.com
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now first up america chan
notices that shigaraki's hair suddenly
got longer and yeah this is true
although i'm not exactly sure if this is
supposed to be some sort of hair based
quirk or if this is just supposed to be
a sign of shigaraki like powering up and
going super saiyan 3. after that brief
hair discussion the clash between
shigaraki and stars and stripes
intensifies even further and by the way
just to avoid confusion when i say
shigaraki i'm referring to both of the
shigerakis who are now residing in the
body of tomorrow after the way that the
previous chapter ended with a mention of
shigaraki's childhood home i was
expecting this chapter to begin with a
flashback to tomorrow's childhood and in
that flashback i was expecting it to be
revealed that little tenko shimura was
actually born quirkless and that decay
was a quirk that all for one transferred
to him without his knowledge however
while that flashback may still be coming
in the future in this chapter we just
got an incredible high-flying
high-intensity showdown and we also got
an extremely important and extremely
long explanation about the true nature
of america john's quirk new order
shiraki believes that he now finally
understands america chan's game-changing
quirk and spoiler alert this quirk is
way stronger than we even imagined
shigeru akiman says that new order is
known as the strongest quirk and it is
so important that the us government
tries to keep the true properties of the
quirk a carefully guarded secret
but shigaraki can tell that there are
still limits to the quirk's powers and
he is hoping to use these limits to his
advantage to win the fight as we saw in
the previous chapter new order allows
its user to impose any rule upon a
target after touching it and calling out
its name the target can be a person an
object and even the atmosphere itself
this power is so fantastically strong
that shigaki wonders whether it can be
called a quirk in the first place its
power is almost godly compared to
regular quirks but after fighting stars
and stripes for some time shigaraki has
now figured out important things about
the quirk first there is a limit to how
much she can strengthen her own body as
we learned in the last few chapters
stars and stripes can impose rules upon
herself and we also know that she can
impose up to two rules at a time so
normally she gives herself super
strength and then she uses the other
rule to attack her opponent but as was
already revealed to us while america
chan can make herself extremely strong
she is not quite as strong as all might
so shigaraki is right the extent to
which she can increase her own physical
strength is limited shigaraki also
believes that she has much greater
freedom in placing rules on things that
are not biological in nature so she
can't just say something like anyone who
is breathing the same air as me will die
otherwise she could have killed
shigaraki already we then get a whole
bunch of text that is trying to explain
the complexities of new order and it's
not all one hundred percent clear but i
will try my best to explain everything
the way that i understand it as
shigaraki observed when using new order
there appears to be a difference between
setting rules for biological and
non-biological targets and shigaki
believes that this difference is related
to the concept of calling the target's
name with biological targets like humans
america chan has to call out their name
and touch them directly and for
shigaraki she called him shigaraki
tomorrow but because he no longer knows
whether he is tomorrow or all for one or
tenko shimura the rule did not work so
for animate objects like human beings
and perhaps other sentient beings stars
and stripes has to call them by a name
that they themselves identify with and
because shigaraki doesn't have a set
identity at the moment the quirk failed
to kill him however for inanimate
targets like the atmosphere around her
amerika-chan could impose a rule on them
based on her own perception of those
targets so if she wants to impose a rule
on something like a mountain something
that doesn't have a conscious identity
only america chan's own perception
matters but for humans their own
perception of themselves is what matters
so shigaraki does seem to have figured
out a lot about new order but there are
still some big unknowns for him
including how many rules she can
activate at once the range of her quirk
and whether it would work on animals
like his former dog monchan now i want
to briefly mention how important it is
that shiitake brought up monchon his
childhood dog and also earlier on he
didn't just say that he doesn't know
whether he is tomorrow or all for one he
said that he doesn't know whether he is
tomorrow or for one or tenko shimura and
then shortly after that he brings up his
dog which is not something that the
shiguraki we know would normally do so
it's almost like tenko shimura's
identity is slowly emerging once again
after all for one spent years trying to
permanently turn tenko into tomorrow
this will likely be important later on
at any rate shigaraki is extremely
impressed with new order and he can't
wait to try it out for himself however
before he can actually do that he will
have to defeat stars and stripes and her
fighter jet squadron in a battle to the
death and that is not going to be an
easy task at the same time though
defeating shigaraki is not going to be
an easy task either as amerika chan's
team members point out shikaraki's
regeneration quirk is so effective that
both new order and their lasers have
failed to have any significant effect if
they are going to actually win this
fight they need a new strategy and then
in the middle of this incredibly intense
fight we get what for me is one of the
funniest moments in mha now we've seen
star wars references before from
tatooine station and jakku city to all
from one's vader-esque mask to name just
a few but what happens next is the most
blatant star wars reference of them all
stars and stripes literally calls a man
named commander akbar who appears to be
her superior and as we find out later on
commander akbar looks extremely similar
to admiral akbar from star wars i mean
references are great but horikoshi is
now straight up risking a copyright
claim because he loves star wars so damn
much as a fellow nerd i have to respect
the man for his commitment anyway stars
and stripes is asking commander akbar to
let her use some top secret special
missiles against shigaraki because he is
no longer a threat to the country of
japan he is now a threat to the entire
world america included and since japan
has all these pesky rules about not
using military-grade weapons against
civilians they need to use the weapons
now while they are still in the air
above japan as the fighter jets continue
to faithfully serve as america chan's
foothold she proceeds to demonstrate the
true terrifying power of new order she
makes the atmosphere solidify and
transform into a version of herself that
is 1 000 times her regular size
shigaraki can't even see this enormous
creation because it is made out of air
itself so it is invisible but he can
feel that something massive has appeared
stars and stripes is then able to use
this giant susano to copy her own
movements and as she herself throws a
punch the gigantic air mecha smashes
shigaraki and sends him flying america
knows that dealing this much damage to
shigaraki is meaningless because he will
just regenerate so she decides to
completely crush him to dust she uses
the palms of her hands to clap shigaki
like he was some annoying insect and
then the fighter jets joined the fray
she tells her squadron whom she calls
her brothers to fire all of their lasers
right at her as the lasers converge upon
her she places a rule on them to harden
and concentrate into a single gigantic
laser beam she then uses her susano to
grasp the laser beam like it was some
sort of spear and she brings it down
right on shigaraki as shigaki crashes
down under the force of this massive
laser beam stars and stripes commands
her squadron to keep shooting lasers at
him until he burns up bro stars and
stripes has the kinds of powers that
were attributed to actual gods in greek
and roman mythology this is really next
level stuff nevertheless america chan
still has a feeling that even this won't
be enough to take shigaraki down for
good if this much force alone was enough
to take him out then endeavour would
have been able to defeat him during the
battle of jakku and that is when admiral
akbar confirms that it's a trap no no i
mean that is when commander akbar
confirms that those special missiles are
on the way our boy akbar scolds stars
and stripes for always skirting the
rules and doing only what she wants even
if that means disobeying orders and yet
akbar also says that this type of
attitude is the reason why their country
america
shines so bright akbar adds that even
all might couldn't capture this
particular villain so this is the time
for stars and stripes whose real name is
kathy to surpass her master no offense
to anyone named kathy but that's not a
very badass name so i'm glad she went
with stars and stripes we then see an
old photo of all might actually holding
a young stars and stripes probably soon
after he saved her and her family from
those villains in california this
confirms that she has actually met all
might in person and that she didn't just
admire him from afar as the hero who
saved her the chapter ends with a bunch
of hypersonic intercontinental cruise
missiles named tiamat heading for
shigaraki's location and so even though
the previous chapter hinted at the
possibility of the battle between
chicago and stars and stripes coming to
an end in this chapter that is clearly
not what happened but i am not
disappointed because this chapter and
these revelations about new order were
just unbelievable what stars and stripes
was able to accomplish here creating
that giant susano thing out of thin air
and then using it to wield that huge
spear made of laser beams is well beyond
the capacity of even the strongest
quirks we've seen thus far this quirk
although it does have limitations seems
to give its user near godly powers i
mean you can't even properly compare the
power of this quirk to any other quirk
we've seen before with the possible
exceptions of one for all and all for
one and those two quirks can compare
only because they allow the user to use
a bunch of different quirks at once
anyone trying to take on stars and
stripes using just a single quirk would
just be absolutely wrecked on the spot i
mean imagine using like minata's quirk
or cerro's quirk against stars and
stripes just
no
it appears that after almight's
retirement stars and stripes became the
strongest hero not only in america but
in the entire world and i think that
this is a totally justified title her
quirk is a game changer it makes us
rethink how quirks work and what they
are capable of and if anyone can stand
up against awakened chicagy other than
deck when one for all it is definitely
stars and stripes and new order okay now
you guys have to tell me what you
thought of this chapter and how insane
new order appears to be i mean it was
straight up referred to as the strongest
quirk by shigaraki and although it does
have limitations when used properly i
think this really could be the strongest
quirk it is just so powerful and so
incredibly versatile and if stars and
stripes ever got an additional power up
that took away some of those limitations
or if she ever ingested the trigger her
power would be straight up godly it
would be on a completely other level
from normal human quirks let me know
what else you think that new order can
do and how do you think this insane
fight is going to end since all 41 and
all might burnt at their prime the last
time we saw them fight awakened
shigaraki and stars and stripes are
easily the strongest characters we've
ever seen engaging in a fight of this
caliber and it really shows the sheer
scale of this fight is on a whole other
level from what we've seen before and
now with hypersonic missiles entering
the chat it's only going to get bigger
from here and speaking of those missiles
they are named tiamat which was the name
of a primordial goddess of the sea in
ancient babylonian religions now
normally i wouldn't think that
conventional weapons like missiles would
ever play a major role in any big mha
fight but with the medikachan's ability
to potentially place rules on these
missiles you never know she could end up
using them in ways we're not expecting
so we'll have to wait and see all in all
this chapter was crazy and extremely
important to the story as i said many
times before new order is a game changer
and we need to pay close attention to
this fight because mha will never be the
same after this if you enjoyed this
video and you're as excited as i am to
see where this goes next definitely
leave a like it takes a second but it
helps a lot and of course if you're new
to the channel or you watch our videos
we just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all i know it's
annoying but unless you go through those
steps you're still gonna miss a lot of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror thanks again to manscape.com
for sponsoring this video check them out
link in the description and use the
coupon code anime uproar as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you